je vous proposais quelque chose je vous
venez avec moi chez mon père
m'accompagne et vous restez un peu vous
repartirez plus tard mais qu'est ce que
je vais faire chez votre père ils se
marient pas il se remarie je voudrais
quelqu'un avec moi
je veux embrasser la mariée voilà c'est
laura ya un caribou quidam naître il a
deux têtes tu le vois ok ouais avec elle
depuis longtemps à ces se rend compte de
la chance que tu as eu quand même
grandir dans un zoo
cora colline macère salut
bonjour mon fils je me demandais si je
vais devoir je suis là quelque part je
vais dormir à côté du nid à nous n'est
pas du tout tu peux dormir avec moi
sauf si toi tu as peut-être peur que
cette façon truc à sa frappe n'inquiète
pas
on parle de mariage c'est peguy puis se
marier une semaine de la note va nous
coûter un max de fric ce tube pâte
mariette mois ci à faire pas elle sait
ne pas créer déguisé en fille jane s
quatre ans qui lui était fait pour le
sol est saturé de caches ta ville
mettez-vous toi [ __ ] moi je suis tous
les jours est-ce qu'on peut compter sur
vesoul dans cette famille
il paraît que dans les actes se cache
toujours le désir mon enfant qui cherche
être aimé de sa famille
plus difficile dans la vie c'est de
trouver quelque part dans le monde
quelqu'un qu'on aime plus que sa famille
ouais
e
m